[موسيقى]
كلمه فسيفساء بتعني مجموعه من الاشياء
تتجمع مع بعضها عشان تقوي لنا موضوع واحد
عنده قيمه قد تكون جماليه قد تكون نفعيه
قد تكون جماليه اللي هو عمل فني مجموعه من
الخامات انا بجمعها مع بعض بعمل بها العمل
الفني بتاعي ده يسمى
[موسيقى]
بداياتي انا في فن الفسيفساء كانت في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تقريبا 2004
كان في واحد بيشتغل
لوحات بتاعت فلوسها وكان داس المساله
بتاعه كيف بيتم عمل اللوحه بتاعه الفصي في
فانا كنت شغوف انه انا اكون لازم اعرف هو
بيشتغل كيف
فالمساله ذلك كانت عامله لي ليه لانه انا
شايف المنتوج بتاعه وشاف المنتوج بتاعه
وعاجبني جدا جدا وحسن ممكن انا اشتغل
الشغل ده لكن داير اشوف كيف الطريقه فدي
البدايه بتاعه الشغف بتاعي بيفن جيت
السودان 2007 كانت بدايتي مع دكتور عادل
كبيده 2010 مشيت القاهره فتشت مواد جبتها
بديت اجرب براي 2013 كان شاركته في اول
ورشه بتاعه رسم الوجوه بالفزاء
[موسيقى]
الشغفين انا الفسيفساء حسيت انه هي ماده
قد تكون عصيه صعبه انك تحول
لوحه فنيه انت تجيبها من خلال حجر او قطع
بتاعه قزاز او اسكراب بتاع سيراميك تكون
عمل فني هو فن نادر في السودان حسيت انه
انا ممكن انطلق منه ممكن القى ليه فضاءات
ارحب عشان اشتغل فيكم واكون انا اول زول
اشتغل الفندق في السودان
[موسيقى]
لوحه المطار عند قصه مؤثره جدا عندي طبعا
هي لوحه المطار دي كان 2015 انا كنت مشارك
في مهرجان في تونس
وانا مسافر
في الجوازات قابلين العسكري بتاع الجوازات
فقال لي انت فنان تشكيلي قلت له نعم قام
قال لي طيب
قلت له انا فنان تشكيلي وبشتغل شغل في
السودان ما في حد بيشتغله والحمد لله لكن
ليك علي التزام ان انا اجي اشتغل لك لوحه
للمطار انا اللي عجبني في الموضوع انه هو
ما قال عايزه لنفسه فعشان كذا اصريت ان
انا اشتغل للاسف الشديد طيله الفتره دي
وانا ببحث عنه
ما لقيته من فتره حكايه بتاعت سنه وحاجه
سمعتها انه يتوفى على العموم اللوحه هي
موجوده وانا عايز اسلمها اداره المطار
[موسيقى]
اللوحه دي انا اشتغلت اول حاجه الخامات
بتاعتها عباره عن بلاط زي ما شايفين بلاط
ازملت وده الاسكراب بتاع القزاز اللي هو
الزجاج المعشق ويعت في الارضيه والسما
والمباني على البلاط لانه شويه منتظم فهي
في العام منظر لشكل السوق السوداني
المتعارف عليهم الفنده لازم ينتشر في
السودان لازم الجداريات دي تملا الشوارع
الجداريه هي وسيله تعبيريه للفنان هي
متاحه للجميع فهي لحظه انت بتشوفها وبتقعد
زي ما قلنا مدى طويل
فاتمنى انه الشوارع بتاعتنا تبقى فيها
جداريات تبقى فيها لوحات
[موسيقى]